well we can get some immediate reaction
from the nurses Union the women that
we've been talking about a little bit in
that interview uh the Royal College of
Nursing Pat Cullen and the union says
that its members will be walking out
tomorrow and it wants direct pay
negotiations with the government well
let's speak now shall we too uh the
general secretary and chief executive
Pat Cullen thank you very much for being
with me uh today uh we've just heard
from Maria Caulfield who says that the
strikes aren't really about pay they're
only a smaller element about paying it's
more about conditions is that right
so that's an absolutely not true and I
heard Maria describe
um and quite a disparaging way pay has
just been a tiny thing for our nursing
staff our nursing staff are on the
breadline they're not able to afford
their bills there are some of them
aren't even able to afford travel to get
to their work for goodness sake and yet
we have a minister sitting here saying
that it's about all of the other things
and not about pay that is absolutely not
true of course there are many other
terms and conditions we would like this
government to sort out for our nurses
absolutely but pay is fundamental if we
are going to try and keep the nurses
we've got in the Health Service and try
and recruit more than 50 000 vacancies
in this country and if we don't address
pay then I'm afraid I most nurses would
say to you tonight they are fearful for
where the Health Service will end up
right let's talk about pay then shall we
let's talk about numbers
um you open negotiations asking for 19
at pay rise at five percent above
inflation the government said that's
unaffordable what would you accept
I said we'd get around a table and talk
about this uh but I heard you mention
about the meeting that I had with um
Steve Barkley a few days back and once
again brought into a room and told you
can talk about anything you wish to talk
to me about but we will not be talking
about pay and until I can get into a
room and talk about pay to the ministers
then I'm afraid I'm not going to
negotiate for the hundreds of thousands
of nurses that will be on picket lines
tomorrow over the airwaves but they owe
those nurses
um everything to get into a room and
start to talk about pay surely to
goodness that's the only respectful
thing they could do at this stage
instead or instead of what they're doing
they are allowing those hundreds of
thousands of nurses to actually go on to
picket lines tomorrow and stand out in
the cold when they want to be inside
looking after their patients but this is
kind of the point though isn't it
because you've said yourself that the
health secretary isn't talking to you
about numbers
um and yet the government is making a
huge play that fact that you want a 19
pay rise they clearly feel that that
plays into their hands that most people
listening will think it's unaffordable
so surely this is your opportunity to
give a bit of guidance on what you would
accept so in Scotland for example uh
there's been an accepted offer of 7.5
would you accept that
look we had an opportunity to stop the
spin and start to speak a few days ago I
was very optimistic going to that
meeting hoping that at least we would
have some sense shown
um and then we could actually have
stopped the strike tomorrow but in fact
that was never going to be on the cards
for this government they brought us into
a room they marched us up to the top of
the hill again and they abandoned our
nursing staff the 320 000 nurses that
have voted for for strike action that's
an incredible and significant mandate
and you cannot ignore their voices you
absolutely cannot they're not asking for
uh as I keep saying their pockets to be
lined with gold they're wanting a decent
decent wage that isn't they're entitled
to a decent wage and if we are going to
try and address the issues within our
Health Service we need to retain our
nurses that we've got in the Health
Service those nurses that Maria talked
about today on your program that are not
able to get their annual leave they're
not able they're working every R that's
available to them to keep the Health
Service going and actually when you talk
about the 19 we never asked for 19
in February of this year we submitted
our evidence to the peer review body and
at that point inflation was not sitting
where it is now and then in July uh the
the government accepted the
recommendation of the pay-per-view body
I never accepted the recommendations nor
did our nurses and inflation wasn't
where it is now either and so the more
they've tried to release the longer
they've tried their helis and Fletcher
has continued to rise and consequently
we're sitting at 19 but what I would say
to Maria and to Steve Barkley and any
other minister listening can you afford
not to do this and indeed the
international Council of nurses wrote to
Steve Bartley this evening and told them
plainly and squarely that he cannot
afford not to do it either so you're
saying you never asked for 19 just this
is your chance though to clear it up and
I know you know I understand what you're
saying about you know you don't want to
negotiate on the Airways but I do feel
as well that you know nurses are going
on strike the public have a right to
know exactly what it is you're striking
for I just don't understand why you
won't be a bit more specific on what
kind of pay rise you think would be you
know Fair
no I'm definitely not going to negotiate
on the airwaves and I don't think that
any Minister should reduce or a
profession to have to do that they
should they should do the decent thing
and get into a room and negotiate with
me I've also said if they find that that
maybe isn't isn't suitable for them that
we will do it through conciliation and
engage with aircast I don't think that's
very much for our profession to ask and
I don't think that any Minister should
suggest or ask that we would negotiate
on Airways and not give us the respect
and get into a room with us uh okay
um if the government doesn't uh do what
you're asking to you get around the
table and negotiate on pay should we
expect to see more nurses strikes
well the the
um the balls in their Court quite
frankly uh there will be a second day on
the 20th of December and unless we have
um talks and unless we are able to
negotiate on behalf of my members then
I'm afraid to say that that's that's a
very strong possibility and already we
will be starting to look at when those
deaths will be
so what kind of time frame would be
you're saying you'll be looking at what
when that could be what kind of time
frame are we looking at then potentially
I'm afraid that they will continue into
January okay that's a really interesting
uh to hear uh certainly uh something uh
sobering as well if you look at the
current waiting times operations in the
NHS and what do you think the impacts of
the strikes will be
well just when you mentioned waiting
lists I think that's a really important
point
um why are those nurses going on picket
lines tomorrow and losing a day's pay
out of the meager salaries that they
that this government has
um insisted that they live on that they
can't live on actually
uh but our waiting lists are at 7.2
million uh people in this country
waiting year on year and waiting lists
languishing on waiting lists and why are
they because we haven't got the nurses
to be able to care and treat those
patients so the ministers will continue
to talk about if we take money from
um the elective care waiting lists and
and give it to the nurses then we won't
be able to attract and address the
elective care waiting lists but you'll
address new waiting lists if you do not
have the nursing staff to actually care
and treat those passions they're
actually one of the same thing so this
is again all part of the spin that's put
on this about taking from patients and
given to nurses it's nurses that look
after patients and without nursing staff
patients in this country are getting a
pretty raw day sitting on waiting list
year after year when their treatments
should be given to them at a time when
they require them and then they can get
on and live their fruitful and normal
lives and and continue to contribute to
society when in fact because of the ill
health and the increases in the real
health and their chronic conditions they
can't do that so everything leads back
everything leads back to paying nurses a
decent wage and ensuring we can recruit
staff into the Health Service and retain
those nurses we've got I was quite
struck by some comments that you made
after the meeting with Steve Barkley you
said that you thought the government was
displaying particularly Metro Behavior
towards the Royal College of Nursing
because it sees nursing as female work
and doesn't value it properly do you
think there is some sexism in the way
that nurses are treated
I absolutely do and in fact again I
refer back to the international Council
and for nurses and they have addressed
that in the letter to Steve Barkley this
evening as well so it's a well-known
fact that nursing staff is at 90 female
profession
and if you think of some of the things
that this government has um done over
this last number of weeks uh I have to
ask
um them would they do that if those if
those statistics were different if we
were not a 90 female profession
so just one example where they have
decided that the military can come in
and uh with a few hours of training and
take on the role of a nurse take on the
role of caring for patients and there's
not a single nurse in this country would
suggest that with a few hours training
that they could go out and put on a
military uniform and take a gun and do
what our military does because they
absolutely could not and but yet it
seems to be that the value of caring is
brought down to the lowest common
denominator and it can be done by anyone
with a few hours training and that's
just so wrong if you look at what the
government has done with saying they're
going to put in more Draconian
legislation to ensure that through their
trade unions nursing cannot have a voice
that's about trying to silence those
nurses the 90 90 female profession that
we are and I could go on there's many
more examples that I could use but I'm
not alone in thinking this then
International currency of nurses believe
it as well and indeed the people that I
represent believe it